good afternoon everyone good to see you
thanks for joining us today obviously a
few of you are at the geography the
incursion excursion I guess everything's
an incursion these days right so for
those of you the faithful who are here
thanks for being here and we're gonna
get started as you can see on areas of
compound regions this is actually gonna
be the first part of a two-part lesson
so make sure you hang around for
tomorrow for the stunning conclusion now
I want you to think back to when we were
in year 7 you ain't actually even
earlier than that when we were first
learning how to work with areas of
shapes so that sounds like a loud plane
overhead I promise that's not floral
look at areas of flame shapes triangles
rectangles circles all the rest we
learnt their formulas and what would
happen is you might get given a single
shape and then they would say hey work
at the area of this shape or if we
really wanted to throw a curve ball at
you we would give you the area and then
say there might be some algebra some
pronumerals like therefore find the
radius of this circle if it has that
area one of the very natural ways that
we develop that knowledge was then to
say well what if we gave you some
combination of those kinds of shapes
like a square with a circle cut out of
it or a circle with a triangle cut out
of it right so these we call these guys
composite figures and there was a very
basic strategy here we combined all
those formulas and areas of plane shapes
that we knew and then we several these
guys just made up of several of those
pieces you've got to know when to add
them together you've got to know when to
subtract as well but in principle these
problems were no more complicated than
the ones we were doing before there was
just a little extra work to do those so
when we talk about compound regions in
integral calculus we mean things like
this regions where there's lots of
different parts you've seen before we've
had to look at you know positives and
negatives and treating them differently
so we're gonna see versions of that
today and tomorrow as well now the first
thing I want to point out and it's a
number one just follow-up from last
lesson a number two a response to some
of the working that we've been seeing
coming from you guys when you send in
question
you're having trouble with some of the
problems please make sure you follow the
same series of steps that we said for
all the earlier questions when you're
dealing with integrals and the questions
area that you must must sketch if they
don't give you a diagram it's essential
even if they do give you a diagram often
the diagram needs to be drawn on and you
need to like work out all the bits of
pieces and how they fit together
you must draw okay now I know a lot of
you will do anything to avoid graphing
and sketching and honestly I can relate
to that because in the first instance
it's time-consuming and it's hard and
you're like I'd rather do the other
stuff that are much better at and much
quicker at that I promise you for these
questions they're really an essential
piece of the puzzle it's a little bit
like trying to drive without any
rearview mirrors it's like how do you
know what's going on around you how do
you know when you're supposed to change
lanes like you can't see and in the same
way you're working out areas if you
can't see them you're sort of setting
yourself up for trouble so we're going
to sketch with these compound regions
you're going to see if it step through
they're identifying the integral there's
a little more work to there because of
the complexity of the kinds of shapes
we're looking at and then the last thing
is very very similar we're going to
combine whatever areas we've got perhaps
we need to subtract some we need to add
some and then we come up with a
conclusion so that's enough preamble
let's have a look at our first example
I've given you one here where I provided
the sketch for the next question I'm not
going to provide you a sketch so I'm
just warming you up right now however
wherever you're at this question you
still need to have your own sketch here
so let me talk through what we've got
whilst you in your piece of paper and
draw a picture of what we've got here so
it says find the shaded area which I
hope you can see in purple there and the
area is bounded between three different
lines you've got this straight line y
equals x in red you've got this blue
line the concave down parabola and then
lastly you've got the x axis underneath
okay now in order to find this shaded
area even though it's all together in
one piece it actually is a compound
region a compass a figure if you like in
disguise because there isn't
nice the integral that you can write
that gives you that entire area this in
this area you can see here is not
underneath a curve it's underneath
multiple curves so our strategy here is
to work out well let's take one piece at
a time and work out each individually so
for now if you've got a rough sketch of
this and if you can't quite read it
there by the way it's y equals x and
then y equals 4 minus x squared on 9 I
hope you've got a rough version of this
in your book now because we're now going
to use this diagram as our mechanism for
trying to chart a path through here ok
so this is I guess if you like the
second half of the sketch step now what
I've got is you can see here this part
is a straight line actually let me do it
in a clearer color so you can see it
there this part is underneath y equals x
so that's straight line there underneath
that section I can work out this area
here with a single integral ok and that
will give me a value and when I cross
over that red line going to the right
you can see that this section of the
graph here is a whole different curve
right this guy over here is not
underneath y equals x it's actually
underneath the parabola okay so I'm
gonna do deal with each one one at a
time and in fact to help us do that
I'm gonna call this guy a 1 for area 1
and then I'm gonna call this guy a 2 for
area 2 now in order to work out the area
of this first shape I want you to notice
I did say we could work out a single
integral that will enclose this red area
a 1 but in fact I want you to think back
a few lessons I don't even need to use
that much heavy-duty mathematics to work
this out and the integration is not
required because this is a simple kind
of shape what kind of shape will we got
here guys can you write down the formula
we're going to use in the chat we need
to see a few people wake up to that yes
very nice max that wouldn't be the way
that I write it but it'll do for me okay
yes good I was starting to see this is
our area of a triangle formula right now
obviously to work out the area of a
triangle I need some dimensions as you
guys are mentioning I need a base
our height as well so this is not
something that's provided to us and I've
given you very deliberately no grid so
you can't just read off the coordinates
so how will I find out the coordinates
of or I should say the dimensions of
this triangle okay well I hope you can
recognize that the key piece of
information wrong color the key piece of
information is the coordinates of this
intersection point well done Sasha okay
fantastic we spotted if I can work out
where that intersection point is sort of
really lucky for me it's almost like I
set this up to be a straight forward
example that same set of coordinates is
going to give me firstly the height of
my triangle and also the base so why
don't we go ahead and work that out to
find the intersection point and I'm even
going to write down that that's what I'm
doing again so that I don't have these
random equations just coming out of
nowhere I want to communicate why it is
that I'm working out what I'm working
out how do I find the intersection point
between two curves can you guys go ahead
and tell me in the image have what am I
going to do to locate that any
suggestions simultaneous equations in
again with the first fantastic okay
you're very good so what I've got in a
sense is looking over here in the top
right hand corner I've got an equation
here an equation here and I'm gonna
solve them simultaneously now since
they're both provided to you with Y
being the subject I can just let them be
equal to each other and then go ahead
and solve so let's have a go with that
I'm solving for 4 minus x squared on 9
there's the parabola for that being
equal to X okay so this looks a bit
messy let's let's try and simplify this
a little bit I'm going to get rid of all
the fractions so I'll multiply through
by 9 that gives me 36 takeaway x squared
equals 9x and then I'm going to
rearrange this a little bit so I might
add x squared to both sides and subtract
36 from both sides so that would leave
me with 0 on the left hand side and it
would leave me with x squared plus 9x
minus 36 on the right hand side okay
all right so now I've got this what am I
gonna do with this well what am i trying
to find again I want to find an x value
this satisfies this right so I'm going
to look for a pair of factors that'll
help me out so has anyone already worked
out the pair of numbers that's going to
be useful to me here I want them to add
to 9 and multiply to negative 36 okay
fantastic well done yeah I'm very proud
of you so I want plus 12 negative 3 so I
go X plus 12 X minus 3 that equals 0 and
I can see from each of those factors
each one will give me a solution so you
can see that this factor here will give
me a solution of x equals negative 12
and then the second factor over here
gives me a solution of 3 now we were
solving a quadratic so we shouldn't have
been that surprised that we got two
solutions but I don't want two solutions
I only want one of them so which is the
one that's relevant and how can you tell
any suggestions out of these two values
which is the one I want to focus on okay
I'm seeing a few answers turning up can
anyone tell me for bonus points why like
how did you know that that was the value
3 that I should be focusing on okay yes
excellent
well max it is easier but that's not a
legitimate reason
in fact sometimes you're gonna have to
choose the other one in this case as
many of you either have identified I
want the positive one not because it's
above the x-axis but because it's to the
right of the y-axis these are X values
so that's horizontal right so um an x
value you could be to the right and I
could still be down so it's not about
being above or below the x-axis it's to
the right of the y-axis and I guess
another way Sasha has said it's in the
the top the first quadrant I guess would
be the way we say it